you
the Vatican Secretary of State's
secretary I don't know why I said it
like that but I did let's just go with
it
the Secretary of State said today that
Frances Pope Francis is serene right now
he's feeling serene despite the
allegations against him and that is that
that's nice isn't it is that nice to
hear
he's serene the entire Catholic world
has descended in the moral chaos but the
Pope is serene great so wonderful to
hear and of course the Secretary of
State did not answer any questions about
the substance of the allegations he
didn't have anything to say about that
it has been now four days since the Pope
was credibly accused of personally
covering up sex abuse and this has been
the Pope's response nothing not a word
but he is serene so so that's good now
the Vatican has issued no statement
about these allegations it did issue a
statement though yesterday about
something and I remember I saw you know
I finally saw the headline and I had
before I read the entire headline but
it's a Vatican issues statement and then
I said finally
but then I saw that know that the
statement was to clarify comments that
Pope Francis had made which had offended
gay people they people were concerned
that Francis had said something that
sounded like he was implying the
homosexuality is a mental disorder
so the Vatican quickly clarified that I
mean they came out and they said no they
issued that clarification right away
because that's very important this is
the Vatican's priority you say it cares
about soothing the hurt feelings of gay
people but as for the spiritual chaos
and despair of devout Catholics
everywhere it has no evident concern now
has anybody offered a plausible defense
of the Pope
well the the the liberal Cardinal cupich
who is a disgrace of a man and an
embarrassment to Christians everywhere
he said that Pope Francis Pope Francis
you know doesn't have time to worry
about this because he's too busy
protecting the environment and caring
for immigrants and so he's too busy with
all that to bother with these
allegations that's actually what he said
and he also said that he thinks the
criticism of Pope Francis is really
rooted in bigotry against against
Latinos
now I don't even think that such a thing
is we should dignify such a such a
comment with a response but I will
respond to it anyway to say number one
that is idiotic you disgrace of a man
number two
Pope Francis is he's a he's a an Italian
is ethnically Italian born to Italian
parents in Argentina so
I think the racism charge considering
he's a white Italian man is you know
that's that that's that's a hard what
it's gonna be hard to make that land
okay now the leftist media they claim
that there's a coup going on against the
innocent Pope Francis being waged by
terrible conservatives and then you have
people in the church who have been
attempting to deflect from all this by
slandering Archbishop vigan Oh who's the
man who made these allegations accusing
him of his own sex abuse cover-up now
he's come out against those accusations
and and offered documentation to prove
that they're false
so vegan Oh has you know he came out
with the original allegations and he has
and he was accused of something he came
out with documentation proving that it's
false so he's very open and he's
responding and he's engaging as opposed
to pretty much every person who was
indicted by his allegations they've all
just clammed up and had nothing or very
little to say besides which as I as as
I've already said it doesn't really
matter
even if vegan Oh were guilty of a sex
abuse cover-up but she doesn't seem that
he is but even if he had done that
doesn't matter what he's guilty of he
can be guilty of the JFK assassination
doesn't matter
it has no relevance to the fundamental
question the fundamental question is
is it was it true is it true the
allegations that he made are they true
that's all that matters
and the weakest defense of all of course
offered for Pope Francis is the one
offered by Pope Francis it's weak
because it's non-existent he offers no
defense
he gives us no explanation he just waves
us off dismissively and says basically
run along I don't care which is by the
way what he's been doing to faithful
Catholics for six years can we imagine
innocent man would behave this way
it's hard to imagine
it's hard to imagine it's hard to
imagine that an innocent man would face
these allegations and have nothing to
say whatsoever but Pope Francis has
cover while he hides and it is as I said
cover from the liberal media
I am fully accustomed to seeing the
leftist media live mislead slander spin
false narratives I am not at all
accustomed to seeing them lie mislead
slander and spin false narratives for
the sake of the Vatican okay that is
these are very strange times that is a
as I said I will never get used to that
if you told me ten years ago that I
would be that I would be going after the
Pope while the media protects him
I would have been highly skeptical then
again if you had told me that Donald
Trump would be President and Dennis
Rodman would be our ambassador in North
Korea I also would have been skeptical
about that as well said but these are
the times we're living in
of course the primary lie that we're
hearing from the media with regard to
all of this is that is that this is an
ideological battle that's what they're
telling us this is a battle of the
conservatives versus the enlightened
progressives there was a headline on
Reuters yesterday that said defenders
rally around Pope fear conservatives
escalating war yes conservatives are the
ones escalating things it's our fault
it's our fault it's not the fault of the
homosexual networks in the church who
have been covering up sex abuse for
decades no no it's not their fault it's
the fault of conservatives you see
now what I want to do is I want to
address the idea that this is all
ideological an ideological war
um
because that's where what you're hearing
everywhere and if you get if you're
getting your news about this from the
leftist media that's probably the
impression you have it's a false
impression for three reasons number one
there's nothing ideological about being
opposed to sex abuse unless we're saying
that opposition to sex abuse is a
uniquely conservative position
number two the ideology of Francis's
critics
um is irrelevant because no matter their
ideological convictions the question
they are asking is valid and non idea
ideological did Francis do it is he
guilty
that's the question it is not an
ideological question and the ideology of
the people asking it is irrelevant on
the other hand Francis's ideology
and the ideology of the cover-up artists
in the Vatican that is relevant because
it could be argued that their liberal
non-judgmental tolerant open-minded
perspective is what led them to support
and promote and protect active
homosexuals in the first place and as
the as the floodgates are being opened
here and more stories are coming out
we're seeing we're seeing this kind of
be fleshed out light LifeSite news has a
has two or three articles about new
allegations from other people in the
Vatican about Pope Francis and they all
revolve around this there they all
revolve around his tolerance for active
homosexuals around him like there's one
where he he gave a Vatican apartment to
a priest who was a known active
homosexual and who had been accused of
sex abuse gave him an apartment knowing
this about him and this is coming from
someone in the Vatican told this to the
to LifeSite news
knowing this about gave it an apartment
and the next thing you know there is
there's a gay drug fueled orgy going on
in a Vatican apartment you know with
with this active homosexual who Pope
Francis had given Department so there's
there's that kind of thing and it would
seem that his liberal ideology is not
irrelevant to this to this fact number
three and this is the most important
thing when it comes to the essential
moral teachings of Christianity there is
no conservative or liberal distinction
there aren't different versions or
varieties okay now conservative versus
liberal that might make sense if we're
talking about in Catholicism something
like the liturgy you know how the mass
is celebrated and so on conservatives
will tend to favor more traditional more
reverent approaches and their view is
absolutely right because the
liberalization and secularization of
worship is an abomination before God but
here maybe you do find a conservative
liberal dynamic where obviously as
always the Liberals are wrong as they
are wrong about basically everything but
when it comes to the moral truths when
it comes to something like the
homosexual act for instance which is
what a lot of this revolves around and
where the suppose at ideological war
hinges in the church but here there is
only one correct Christian position
those who say the act is immoral are not
conservative they're just Christian
those who say that it is not immoral are
they're not liberal they are actually
rejecting the authority of Scripture
rejecting natural law and if they're
Catholic they're rejecting the teachings
of the church that is not a liberal
position that is just an unchristian
position that is a position that as a
Christian is not available to you so
when it comes to these moral truths
there are there aren't different ways of
looking at it there is only one way of
looking at it there is only one truth
there is only one thing you're allowed
to believe if you want to continue being
a Christian now I am not at the moment
interested in discussing whether
Christianity is right about
homosexuality or about any other moral
point that's beside the present point
the present point is simply that
Christianity does have a teaching on
these subjects
that's the point
and if you wish to and if you're not
Christian and you don't you don't agree
with the teachings well fine whatever
you don't have to agree with ten but if
you claim to be Christian you have to
agree with the teachings you can't
disagree with them
um the Bible clearly condemns the
homosexual act repeatedly including in
first Corinthians Romans first Timothy
all across the Old Testament most
notably in Leviticus and Genesis
moreover Jesus Christ himself defines
marriage in both Matthew and Mark he
teaches that marriage is when a quote
man and his quote wife come together and
quote become one flesh he defines
marriage he says this is what marriage
is he offers a definition that's the son
of God
so what we are left with is a full
uncompromising explicit consensus across
both the old and new Testament about the
nature of marriage and the moral
depravity of the homosexual Act every
church for almost 2,000 years
affirmed these teachings no Christian
theologian or thinker of any note or any
legitimacy found or claimed to find any
pro gay interpretation of any of the
verses mentioned above that is because
no such interpretation can be found it
isn't there it doesn't exist we must
either accept with humility the biblical
view on this topic or we must throw the
Bible out and Christianity along with it
and if we're going to do that then we
are not Christian
if we try to retain
progressive views
then we must be doing so on one of the
following three foundations okay so if
you want to say well
no you know homosexual the homosexual
act is fine
or you know or if you want to have a in
general a more liberalized idea of
sexual morality sex outside of marriage
is fine and so forth well if you're
gonna do that then you have to be doing
it on one of the three following three
foundations number one the Bible is
wrong
number two this behavior was wrong
during biblical times but it is no
longer wrong number three the Bible
actually supports this behavior but it's
support is so subtle and hidden that
nobody noticed it for twenty centuries
until we came along and discovered it
now as a Christian the first foundation
the Bible is wrong that doesn't work
because it denies the moral authority of
Scripture and if scripture contains
moral error and so much of it - then we
have no reason to believe anything else
that tells us and if we cannot believe
what it tells us then we have no reason
to believe that our faith is true so
that doesn't work for a Christian that
doesn't for a Christian the second
foundation that this behavior was wrong
during biblical times but it's not wrong
anymore that doesn't work because it it
trades objective morality for moral
relativism but moral relativism is
incompatible with Christianity because
on the Christian understanding morality
is grounded in and flows from in eternal
perfect all-knowing and changeless God
if morality is relative then God is
either imperfect and changeable or
non-existent
number three the third foundation that
doesn't work either that the Bible
actually does support this behavior but
we didn't know it until now that doesn't
work either
leaving aside to the arrogance of that
kind of view where you're saying that
every but every Christian in history was
wrong about this except for you let's
leave aside the arrogance of that the
problem is that it supposes that the
Bible is so confusing and so
incomprehensible that even its clearest
commands and its clearest edicts cannot
be known this view suggests that the
Bible may mean the opposite of what it
says and it may take a couple of
millennia for us to realize it so what
opposite meanings will we discover in
the year 4000 perhaps by then it'll turn
out that the Bible's references to Jesus
as the Son of God actually meant that
he's not the son of God I mean anything
is possible and if anything is possible
then christianity ceases to be
meaningful or intelligible and if it's
not meaningful or intelligible than it
is literally unbelievable it is not
something that a person can believe
because it doesn't mean anything so none
of this works
as a Christian as I said if you're not a
Christian then whatever you could take
any of those positions that you want
doesn't matter you're not Christian
right but if you are a Christian you get
you can't take any of those position of
any of those positions undermines
everything else you believe it
undermines the faith that you pretend to
profess so we are left with only two
valid options be Christian and accept
its moral teachings or don't be
Christian
those are the only that's it
and you can't say well yeah but what if
I think that Christianity is wrong about
this that and the other thing but I
believe that Jesus Christ is the son of
God well but you don't really believe
that do you
because if you're saying that the Bible
is wrong about marriage well Jesus
defined America if you're telling me
that he's wrong about it then you can't
possibly believe that he's divine
because then he can't be wrong
so you've just removed by bite by
claiming that he spoke falsehood
he spoke out of ignorance he spoke out
of whatever bigotry you are removing his
divinity so no you don't believe that
Jesus Christ is the son of God you say
you do but you don't
on the other hand you might say well I
believe he's a son of God no I don't
believe that he said anything wrong but
but he didn't really say those things
that was made up he didn't really say
they they put that into his mouth and
you didn't really say well okay but then
how do you know so that's that part
never happened well how do you know any
of it happen then
how do you know the incarnation have
been adding to the crucifixion heaven I
mean you're getting all of it from the
same document aren't you
you can't do that you you you can't go
through the Bible and start saying well
that didn't happen that then he didn't
really say that now I didn't say that
that's that's false that's completely
wrong
no that moral teaching is incorrect but
yeah that and that that's true
on what basis are you doing that on what
authority were you getting this from
one more thing I think this is a really
important point
when we talk about accepting the moral
teachings you know and I say to be
Christian we have to accept the moral
teachings that is not the same thing as
say I am NOT saying that in order to be
in order to be Christian we have to
follow the moral teachings perfectly or
we cease to be Christian that's not what
I'm saying now we do have to try to
follow the teachings but that's not the
point
obviously nobody follows the moral law
perfectly least of all myself you can be
weak imperfect sinful cowardly and still
be Christian that's Christianity is made
for Jesus says I came to call I didn't
come to call the righteous I came to
call sinners so that's and that's all of
it
and thank God for that because if only
the strongest and most courageous and
most qualified could be Christian then I
would be disqualified personally but
here's what we can't do we can't
categorically reject the moral law
um
and say that it doesn't apply to us we
can't do that we can't say that we
worship God and then in the next breath
say that his Commandments are irrelevant
that doesn't work so that you know I
just think this is a distinction that
for some reason people struggle with so
much does it any time you get into this
conversation people say what does you're
saying we have to be perfect no I'm not
saying we have to be perfect but I mean
we should we strive to be perfect we
strive for holiness but no it's it's
we're not saying that we have to be
perfect right now
you take any moral rule you know we're
not saying you have to follow it
perfectly in order to be Christian but
you have to accept it you have to accept
its legitimacy
you you can't say it's not legitimate
just because you disagree with it or
it's or it's inconvenient or it's hard
you can't do that
as a Christian you can't do that for all
the reasons I've just outlined because
you're tearing down the legitimacy of
Christianity
which it's a you can try to do that from
the outside you can't come into the
inside and do that you can't come into
Christianity and then try to tear down
its legitimacy while claiming to be
Christian and this is also why people
say well why you so you know it comes to
homosexuality what why are you so why
are why are conservative Christians so
obsessed with this issue why are they
talking about it all the time well
number one we're not the ones taught
we're not the ones who are always
bringing it up
it I would much prefer to live in a
society where we didn't need to talk
about this at all where it never came up
but I'm not the one bringing it up there
is a there is a a loud voice out there
including a voice within Christianity or
people who claim to be Christian who
everyday are saying no this is okay we
have to accept it so they're the ones
bringing it up literally marching
through the street
those of us who are conservative
Christian when we resist that and we
oppose them what we're doing is we're
defending the legitimacy of our religion
because that's what's being called into
question it's not specific it's not
about homosexuality exclusively specific
it is about that as well obviously but
that's not that's not just did it's this
conversation isn't happening in a vacuum
the reason why we feel so necessary to
rebuke Christians who hold this view is
because they are undermining that they
are calling into question our religion
itself
and so that's why that needs to be met
met and every every age you know every
era of Christianity there have been
heresies there have been certain aspects
of Christianity that have come under
attack and so those who love the faith
and believe in it it was necessary for
them to rally around that truth and
defend it and become obsessed with it
when they're not obsessed with it it's
just that it is there's a certain pillar
of the faith that sucked that there's a
movement trying to rip it down and so
we've to rally around that pillar and
say no and in our time the heresy
revolves all around moralities but an
especially sexual morality the the
heresy basically is moral relativism
and it's a heresy when it's within
Christianity when you have Christians
who say that morality changes or that we
get to decide what's more and so those
of us who love the faith we have to
rally around objective morality and say
no you cannot tear down this pillar
all right
we'll leave it there thanks for
listening everybody Godspeed